[Musique]
trop de chiens en France où les chiens
nous mènent-ils par le bout du nez pour
répondre à ces questions une invitée de
marque Tara Sardou de saint-cardin la
petite chienne de Jackie Sardou dont
vous dites Jacky que c'est la plus belle
fille du monde la plus belle chienne du
monde elle est ravie quand vous lui
dites
et la plus formidable Jackie Sardou on
vous retrouve aussi tous les soirs au
théâtre Fontaine dans une pièce de
Ginette Garcin qui s'appelle le clan des
veuves
Ginette Garcin moi-même alors face à
Tara il y a Jackie Sardou un homme un
journaliste
un journaliste du Nouvel Observateur
Fabien gruyer qui lui a aboyé alors très
fort dans un livre intitulé bas les
pattes
aux éditions régimes de forges on peut
le dire alors vous vous écrivez que la
France est pourrie par les chiens que
les Français feraient mieux faire des
enfants plutôt que d'entretenir 37
millions d'animaux domestiques et vous
dites même que des chiens employés dans
un musée ce serait bien mieux alors si
je vous ai bien compris il faut se
débarrasser des chiens et très vite je
trouve qu'il y en a vraiment beaucoup
trop la France elle record du monde en
France il n'est
à peu près 1 million de chiens par an
contre 700 000 enfants je trouve que
c'est un déséquilibre un peu bizarre
Jackie Sardou
mais c'est aux gens qui en ont comme
vous madame et ben monsieur moi je vais
vous dire je vous plains beaucoup de ne
pas avoir de chien je vous laisse votre
chien si vous savez vous avez tort elle
voudrait pas de vous d'avoir vu la joie
suffit de nourrir madame pour qu'il soit
content on parle d'amitié
vous faites rigoler vous l'avez acheté
il a pas il vous a pas sauté dessus
parce qu'il vous aimez elle représente
quoi Jackie Sardou
président de la tendresse et surtout
quand on se trouve seul dans la vie
quand on pousse une porte
que personne derrière quand on se
réveille le matin personne pour vous
dire bonjour quand vous vous couchez le
soir personne pour vous caresser
un espèce de médicament pour solitaire
mais c'est pas l'idéal dans la vie je
préfère avoir un chien comme un mec qui
m'embête toute la journée
est-ce que vous la ferez empailler votre
chaîne quand elle se met pas là aussi me
tire pour chien pas du tout mais pas du
tout ça fait plaisir aux gens de les
faire enterrer c'est aussi bien que ça
saouler là c'est un peu ridicule madame
soyez pour créer un impôt sur les chiens
a priori oui parce que je vois pas
pourquoi moi contribuer pas de chien
bien que j'ai un chat
je vois pas pourquoi je devrais payer
toutes ces machines riches shiraken qui
servent à nettoyer les trottoirs enfin
il y a aucune raison que mon argent de
contribuer
pour moi c'est formidable c'est la
confiance c'est la vie c'est la
confiance parce que vous le nourrissez
pour qui vous aime pas rien gruyer lui
il est d'accord pour donc mettre un
impôt sur les chiens sur la connerie il
faudrait mettre un impôts alors là
qu'est-ce qu'on regrets comme fric dis
donc
alors vous me dépasseriez vous vous
savez ce que dit Fabien gruyer hein il
dit qu'en vérité les chiens sont des
cons ils bouffent ce qu'on leur donne et
les mettre de chien sont encore plus
cons que c'est fatigent
j'espère que vous faites pas beaucoup de
petits parce que est-ce qu'un chien peut
être aussi intelligent qu'un homme
est-ce que tu as raison
on a quand même l'impression en lisant
votre livre que vous êtes obsédé par les
crottes vous parlez des crottes à toutes
les pages la façon de leitmotiv bon
évidemment c'est le truc qu'on était le
plus visible c'est souvent pour un chien
et
je reviens
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie dis-donc oh
dis donc depuis 2002
s'il était plus difficile de redouter en
fait un homme qu'un chien non rien du
tout moi-même un mec ça m'a jamais fait
peur
vous parlez aussi de la zoophilie
monsieur parle de la zoophilie dans son
livre vous en pensez quoi
et je recommence vous ne pouvez pas lire
les gens qui ont des chiens ne lisent
pas alors vous allez pas avoir beaucoup
de clients alors je vais vous dire
Jackie Sardou tenez-vous bien vous êtes
assise la conclusion en fait de Fabien
gruyer de sleeve c'est que demain ce
sera pire demain l'animal que votre
voisin du dessus emmènera pisser le soir
ne sera plus un chien mais un cheval
je voudrais pas leur tenir le bout de la
queue moi je vous le dis à mon chien oui
mais pas un mec il y a des tas de villes
qui ont résolu le problème d'une façon
plus ou moins harmonieuse en collant des
amendes aux gens qui qui laissent aller
leur chien et c'est surtout un problème
de civisme des propriétaires de chien
nous sommes bien d'accord mais en France
on n'est pas si vite ah bah en France on
est civique pour hier alors de toute
façon
moi la mienne je lui ai appris à trois
mois de décembre dans un caniveau elle
descend en tous les cas vous n'êtes pas
prête à vous séparer de ta rare j'espère
mais je suis très malheureuse parce que
comme je suis âgé je pense que ce sera
la dernière chaîne que j'aurais c'est
pas un vrai chien c'est un espèce de
bijou artificiel qui a été fabriqué
spécialement pour les mêmes et ben dis
donc
je vais vous dire
déjà pour commencer bon pour vous
consoler vous irez peut-être voir Jackie
Sardou dans le clan des veuves
au moins trois fois le prix de la place
ah ma chérie dis on veut pas écouter je
vous remercie d'avoir
beaucoup de bonshommes que je vois dans
la vie mais celui-là il compte également
comment un mec qui a gagné 7 millions de
spectateurs on peut s'intéresser à
Kaganski ou à quelqu'un d'autre moi je
m'en fous il a qu'à raconter il a caché
devant les cheval moi s'il y a du monde
qui rentre que ce que vous voulez que ça
me foute que grand ski je décaganski ou
un autre ou Austria ou machin ce sont
des mecs qui gagnent 30 balles et qui
nous font chier parce qu'ils sont jaloux
et ça je le sais parce qu'ils envoient
des scénarios chez moi à me demander en
suppliant de de pas lui forcément mais
des collaborateurs à lui pour que je
fasse un film et quand je le refuse et
ben à ce moment-là il me descendent mais
qu'est-ce que je m'en branle moi je
crois pas que ça fonctionne
vous savez ils sont pas tellement il
faut c'est pas un journal c'est un
journal comme un autre c'est pas on le
monte etc Télérama en fait tu avais
ramasser des cathos et moi votre
collaborateur me traite de catholique
alors que lui il fallait merde c'est
c'est complètement débile vous comprenez
vous racontez des conneries mais le
défaut qu'on a nous ce soit le compte
celui-là ou
de s'intéresser à vous pourquoi
s'intéresse à vous pour trois lignes
dans un journal de chiottes pourquoi
voulez-vous que moi je m'intéresse je
vais pas me branler devant votre article
et je comprends pas comment Monsieur
Jeunet est resté 20 minutes à se
demander ce qui se passait parce qu'il
avait vu le 3 lignes moi quand le Canard
Enchaîné cette semaine me fait un truc
je connais pas le mec il m'a jamais
demandé un scénario c'est un titre que
je ne connais pas ici par deux initiales
il s'appelle packaganski il s'appelle PV
alors moi je sais pas qui c'est mais il
dit que mon film est bon il vient pas me
dire que j'ai pas de fric pour faire des
films c'est comme si on me disait
aujourd'hui je suis mal habillé parce
que c'est ce que vous faites dans on dit
il y a Monsieur un ami à moi un ancien
ami écrit dans le monde que le film est
pauvre ici alors on doit cracher sur les
gens pauvres quand vous voyez un mec qui
est mal habillé dans la rue qu'est-ce
que vous faites alors vous lui cracher à
la gueule alors je non mais c'est ce que
vous faites parce que la majorité des
critiques qui ont descendu mon film le
trade de pauvre de nul parce qu'il pas
de fric et ça je ne l'admets pas vous
comprenez parce que Monsieur Tati
n'avait pas un rond quand il a commencé
monsieur Vigot il est mort à l'hôpital
et Monsieur Vigot ont été largement
défendus par les critiques tu parles les
critiques tu connais les critiques moi
je l'ai connu en se baladait personne
n'en voulait de ces films ça faisait 2
ans d'y retourner avec son père
apprenez le cinéma monsieur kavinski
commencer par la prendre avant d'être
rédacteur en chef d'un journal de cinéma
vous y connaissez que dalle voilà loin
voilà c'est tout maintenant je me tais
parce que vous commencez à me faire
chier tous c'est possible qu'on y
connaisse que dalle que dalle
qu'on attaque les cinéastes parce qu'ils
sont pauvres c'est absolument faux
comment mais tout le monde dit que mon
fils n'est pas bon parce qu'il est
pauvre je comprends ça va pas ça il y a
des tas de films qui ont été défendus il
sera mieux fait il y a des tas de films
qui ont été défendus dans les uns
occultibles ou ailleurs des films qui
étaient avec petit budget
pauvre et alors pourquoi moi je veux
dire que c'est pauvre alors qu'à celui
qui est pauvre on lui dit pas qu'il est
beau les critiques ne travaillent pas en
fonction de la personnalité d'un
cinéaste il travaille et il réagissent
en fonction d'un film
par rapport au fait parce que vous
voulez tous faire un film et quand le
film complet
je ne sens parfaitement libre et serein
par rapport à ça j'ai jamais voulu faire
un film Le Festival de Cannes je pense
que beaucoup de gens savent que c'est la
plus grande réunion mondiale des gens de
cinéma et que
c'est la plus grande concentration à la
fois de film puisque dans l'ensemble du
festival l'été satellites on présente
400 films et la plus grande
concentration
en plus de ça la plus grande
concentration de presse du monde
je vais prendre le relais merci beaucoup
je vais prendre le gerbière
1800 journalistes 4 centimes et 35000
professionnels du monde entier
qui sont réunis là pour à la fois faire
l'équilibre entre l'art et le commerce
donc voilà en quelque sorte si vous
voulez ce qu'a été le Festival de Cannes
depuis des années j'étais un peu triste
d'apprendre que Louis mal disait tout à
l'heure que notre rideau de scène était
fragile alors que vous voyez nos
costumes
le Festival de Cannes a toujours suscité
chez les journalistes dans le public
partout
un grand mouvement que ce soit un
mouvement punk que ce soit un mouvement
violent on a vu à chaque fois au
festival de Cannes des événements tout à
fait troublants et je pense que là en ce
moment ce qu'on est en train de vivre
c'est un moment important du festival ça
prouve que le festival ne vit pas
la peine ce genre de vous êtes vous êtes
vous le délégué général du Festival de
Cannes bon et vous êtes un homme
détendu je crois que on n'a pas de
problème on va pas on va pas commencer à
se battre
je suis partout journal collaborateur
nous le savons pas été abattu à la
Libération
vous avez
besoin
alors fini c'est bon une seconde télé en
tout cas tendu et second rappelle les
choses près bon je croyais attaquer
attends tu vas dire un mot parce que
quand même ça devient très grave c'est
plus publicité littérature
de je suis mort
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais simplement dire une chose je
vois que Monsieur Dallier a utilisé le
procédés les plus bas pour faire une
fois de plus pour créer l'événement je
croyais qu'il est simplement l'imitateur
de Chateaubriant je vois que je suis de
tirer le Luron mais c'est pas fort parce
que c'est ignorable
de rappeler les événements et des fêtes
qui existent et que c'est trop bon
le journal je suis parti vous le
connaissez vous ne connaissez pas bon
alors
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est et aussi parce qu'il est
l'auteur d'un livre que publie Les
Éditions Michel Lafont Kinsky j'ai
besoin d'amour mais moi honnêtement je
ne sais pas si j'interesse colosse
Kinsky parce que vous avez une horreur
absolue on le lit dans votre livre des
gens qui vous parlent des gens qui vous
interviews et surtout en plus ils
étaient d'un mec non c'est le pain c'est
la fille est mignonne mais surtout
femme mais quand on est la maladie tout
ça vous connaissez bien mais bien sûr
mais
ça dépend un peu ça parce que j'ai eu
tellement mal dans l'interviews qui sont
toujours en général des trucs gratuits
alors je demande des vraiment toujours à
l'élément de légende de demander à la
réaction est-ce que c'est une fille
c'était une fille et ça va est-ce que
les jolies autrement il dit toujours
jolie et alors
j'ai fait le rendez-vous toujours là où
je pouvais jamais alors c'est arrivé
comme ça
voulez-vous les jolies pour les baisers
non je voulais jolie parce que c'est
plus sympathique de parler avec une
personne qui est jolie et qui est belle
c'est à dire pas seulement ces trucs
superficiels des comme les nez la bouche
mais
une personne peut être très très belle
par son esprit et son âme voulez-vous
très belle vous voulez vous les femmes
et vous dites j'entraîne tout ce que je
veux attraper comme un fond et je baise
je baise je baise les vendeuses des
serveuses les bonnes les femmes mariées
les maires de famille les [ __ ]
d'Haïti du Mozambique de la Jamaïque des
Français des touristes américaines
s'embrasse il y a tout un paragraphe
mais là elles sont pas toutes belles
quand même celle que
sur le lit par terre aux toilettes sur
le bidet par derrière un genou sur le
ventre debout penchés
pas compris une autre phrase que j'ai
dit qui était très important vers la fin
de livre j'ai dit la plus grande
découverte que j'ai fait dans ma vie et
en regardant le femme c'est tout les
femmes sont belles
si je dis tous les femmes sont belles
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
annule
la discrimination je sais pas quoi là
vous essayez
dans le livre
qui est pas vrai alors la Marianne
discuter sur les choses que je l'écris
là je vous énerve
un peu au début on peut parce que c'est
pas un bon début de parler avec moi et
j'ai fait ça ailleurs j'ai fait ça
partout et depuis toujours aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus conséquent que jamais
parce que je crois pas avant cette
mission cela en notre émission un
article dans le magazine journaux c'est
pas pour nous
c'est pas nous on masturbe la terre
c'est pour le public il faut avoir un
respect pour le public dans le sens il
faut dans un peu plus grand crédit au
public qui ont au moins le même qui ont
donné à soi-même parce que parce que
mais je crois pas les gens à acheter le
livre acheté par le livre c'est pas une
discussion ah vous avez là vous avez
écrit là et là et me mettre un coin
c'est les questions sont pas idiots les
régions sont idiots je ne répond pas
je sais pas j'ai pas le partenaire pour
m'amuser à cette manière là bon alors
dites-moi
écoutez bien avant on continue c'est pas
la peine de continuer de suivre cette
manière parce que
j'ai pas le partenaire pour ça bon alors
le public vous en parlez jamais dans
votre livre
qu'est-ce que ça va nous apporter comme
supplément d'âme le virtuel alors dans
l'avenir et dans ce siècle
la distance l'époque elle ussern la
phénoménologie
j'étais en train de parler de
d'abstraction il semble il semble que
pour certains observateurs comme le
roi-gourant le progrès de la
civilisation viens de la capacité
l'absorption
en train de dire que le progrès
l'abstraction et cette abstraction
aujourd'hui c'est la capacité à se
distancer et se mettre hors de soi-même
et vous vous mettez mort de vous-même
pour avoir plus de conscience de
vous-même et donc j'essaye de dire c'est
que aujourd'hui avec
le virtuel nous avons une capacité
d'abstraction supplémentaire qui va nous
faire faire progresser en au moins
c'est le plus grand mensonge de
l'histoire de l'humanité le seul progrès
actuellement ce serait le saut du tigre
dans le passé faire la révolution c'est
remettre en place des choses très
anciennes mais oubliez celui-là il était
pas subversif il s'appelait Peggy
c'était un bon français alors
[Musique]
bon
courrez à la Bible vous courez à la
Bible elle achète Yves pécore sans flash
si bien qu'à la fin elle creva mais vous
serez mort mais c'est les jeunes que
vous faites crever les générations
futures que vous programmez
il y a jamais une seule époque dans
l'histoire de l'humanité ou les
générations étaient programmées pour
trois ou quatre générations en avant ça
c'est jamais vu et c'est ça la barbarie
c'est au-delà de la barbarie on en est à
la férocité
des images allez nous donner un
supplément d'âme pourquoi et de quelle
façon et de quelle manière
ecoutez moi je connais un prophète qui
disait que Nini valait disparaître sous
les eaux et puis finalement il s'est
plaint que Ninive n'est pas disparu sous
les eaux je crois pas aux grands
prophète du grand soir je crois pas
cette espèce de déversement de hargne et
de Bill et de haine je crois que le
monde va grosso modo vers quelque chose
qui s'appelle l'avenir moi je pense
vous êtes haineux et moi je peux vous
dire que moi l'avenir de l'aide et je
pense que le grand message que j'ai
envie de donner à l'avenir c'est un
message d'amour parce que moi j'ai 3
enfants et ils vont vivre cela et vous
vous avez simplement un tombereau de
haine et d'un jour à déverser je vous le
connaissez pas vous m'avez agressé vous
avez même pas qui je suis et vous me
traitez de l'argent de la CIA mais c'est
incroyable vous êtes haineux et ceci est
absolument insupportable mes amis et
vraiment je comprends pas que vous soyez
à ce point tombereau comme ça de haine
noire et vous parlez allemand et vous
parlez allemand avec une espèce de haine
qui est incroyable et vraiment je suis
hors de moi
simplement dire une chose une seule
chose je crois que la vie est compliquée
le monde est complexe il se globalise et
bien on va pourtant vers des choses qui
sont vers du plus et je le sens
on a montré un aveugle qui était équipé
d'un d'un casque stéréo qui était relié
par satellite il pouvait se promener
dans le monde réel en étant connecté par
satellite à une carte qu'il portait sur
son ordinateur c'est bien qu'il pouvait
se promener dans le monde réel en étant
guidé par les sons et donc il existe
dans un espèce de serre sonore virtuel
correspondant au réel donc l'opposition
réelle virtuelle était vraiment Fantine
et simpliste aujourd'hui le virtuel est
en quelque sorte une sorte d'ange
au-dessus du réel qui vient aider le
réel et c'est pas en train tu pars
c'est un peu aussi ce qui s'est passé
pendant la guerre du Golfe c'est aussi
ce qui est possible
vous chantez bien Jean-Marie je
comprends que vous mettiez en scène des
opéras dans le fait que Gumble ça gagne
la guerre c'est pire que les nazisme
[Musique]
un point vous inimaginez pas à quel
point je suis déçu
[Musique]